hay una gran y deliciosa manzana que
está colgando de una rama ustedes
quieren esta manzana pero no pueden
trepar al árbol por fortuna tienen una
naranja en el bolsillo
así que toman la naranja la avientan
para tirar la manzana que por supuesto
cae así que ahora ustedes ya tienen la
manzana y la naranja pero si no es su
árbol de manzana
va a ser un manda lismo frutal así que
asegúrense de sólo recoger sus propias
manzanas para que todo sea conforme a la
ley pero este también es un problema de
colisión en física podemos calcular las
velocidades involucradas y las masas y
momentos involucrados también usando la
conservación del momento vamos a poner
algunos números vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar algunas cantidades digamos que
esta manzana es bastante grande y tiene
una masa de puntos 7 kilogramos y la
naranja no es tan grande va a tener una
masa de 0.4 kilogramos
digamos que la velocidad de la naranja
justo antes de la colisión es de 5
metros por segundo nosotros lanzamos la
naranja con esta ruta pero justo antes
de golpear a la manzana tenía una
dirección horizontal y una velocidad de
5 metros por segundo y digamos que la
manzana comenzó a moverse a 3 metros por
segundo justo después de la colisión una
de las preguntas que nos podemos hacer
es si esta es la velocidad de la manzana
después de la colisión cuál es la
velocidad de la naranja después de la
colisión y también hacia qué dirección
fue le llamamos bnb naranja y esta
naranja irá hacia la derecha o hacia la
izquierda
justo después de que ocurrió la colisión
y a veces esto no es tan obvio y ahora
tenemos suficientes datos para poder
resolver esto podemos usar la
conservación del momento y la
conservación del momento dice que si no
existe alguna fuerza externa a nuestro
sistema y aquí nuestro sistema son la
naranja y la manzana si no existe un
impulso externo en estas frutas quiere
decir que el momento total justo antes
de la colisión va a ser igual al momento
total después de la colisión y es
importante indicar que esto es justo
antes y justo después no estamos
hablando desde el momento en que la
persona aventó la naranja y tampoco nos
referimos hasta el momento en el que la
manzana cayó al suelo para la mayor
parte de los problemas de colisión solo
vamos a considerar el momento justo
antes y el momento justo después de la
colisión y esto es porque recuerden que
esta fórmula de aquí solo se cumple si
no existe alguna fuerza externa
solo se cumple si el impulso externo es
cero y ustedes se pueden preguntar bueno
acaso no siempre es cero al menos en
este caso pues no no es tan obvio pero
si ustedes son inteligentes se darán
cuenta de que aquí tenemos la fuerza de
gravedad la tenemos en la manzana y en
la naranja así que esto no significa que
tenemos una fuerza externa y si tenemos
una fuerza externa esto no significa que
tenemos un impulso externo es decir que
no se conserva el momento bueno no
realmente y la razón es que por
principio de cuentas esta fuerza de
gravedad tiene la dirección hacia abajo
así que sólo va a afectar el momento
vertical y aquí sólo estamos hablando
del momento horizontal
yo quiero conocer qué es lo que sucede
con el momento horizontal de esta
naranja y por otra parte la definición
del impulso es la fuerza multiplicada
por la duración del tiempo y digamos que
si estamos hablando del instante justo
antes de la colisión y el instante justo
después de la colisión
punto inicial y final el intervalo de
tiempo entre nuestro punto inicial y
final va a ser tan pequeño que la fuerza
de gravedad casi no va a tener tiempo de
hacerse sentir y como no tiene
oportunidad de actuar pues no habrá un
impulso vertical no tendrá casi un
impulso externo así que ignoramos el
impulso debido a la gravedad ya que el
intervalo de tiempo es tan pequeño que
no le da oportunidad de actuar y con
esto podemos usar la conservación del
momento sin ningún problema como se va a
ver esto bueno pues la fórmula del
momento es masa por velocidad así que el
momento inicial de este sistema es el
momento inicial de la naranja que es de
0.4 kilogramos que es la masa
multiplicada por la velocidad inicial
que es de 5 metros por segundo más la
masa de la manzana 0.7 kilogramos
multiplicado por la velocidad inicial de
la manzana que era de 0 si recuerdan la
manzana estaba colgando de la rama y no
se estaba moviendo así que multiplicamos
esto por 0
por segundo lo que significa que todo
este término va a ser igual a cero ya
que 0 por 0.7 va a seguir siendo 0 y
esto va a ser igual a nuestro momento
final es decir el momento total final
del sistema que va a ser el momento
final de la naranja su masa de 0.4
kilogramos por la velocidad final que es
nuestra incógnita es lo que queremos
encontrar bm este término de aquí
representa el momento final de la
naranja y a esto le tengo que agregar el
momento final de la manzana que va a ser
su masa punto 7 kilogramos recuerden que
cuando estamos hablando de la
conservación del momento no nos
referimos al momento inicial de uno de
los objetos del sistema tiene que ser el
momento total inicial y esto tiene que
ser igual de la misma forma al momento
total final no al momento final de
alguno de los objetos el momento inicial
de todo el sistema tiene que ser igual
al momento final de todo
sistema multiplicamos esto por nuestra
velocidad final que es de 3 metros por
segundo y ahora podemos despejar nuestra
incógnita ya que es una sola incógnita
punto 4 por 5 es 2 kilogramos
metro por segundo + 0 pero no lo
escribimos para que no nos quite espacio
esto es igual a punto 4 por b esto es
igual a punto 4 por b en punto 4
kilogramos por nuestra incógnita bn y a
esto le sumamos puntos 7 por 3 va a ser
igual a 2.1 kilogramos metro por segundo
entonces nuestro sistema inició con dos
kilogramos metros por segundo a la
derecha que es lo que aporto la naranja
y nuestro sistema termina con 2.1
kilogramos metro por segundo que es lo
que tiene la manzana más el momento que
sea que tenga la naranja al final justo
después de la colisión y ustedes me
pueden decir a ver creo que nos
equivocamos aquí dos kilogramos metro
por segundo es igual a
punto 1 kilogramos metro por segundo y
esto más algo como es que este lado
derecho va a ser igual a lo que tengo en
el lado izquierdo pero recuerden que el
momento es un vector y los vectores
pueden ser positivos o negativos
dependiendo de su dirección por lo que
esto nos dice que la naranja va a tener
que tener un momento que va hacia la
izquierda tiene que ir hacia la
izquierda que tiene signo negativo para
que todo esto puede ser igual a lo que
tenemos del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación así que sabemos que la
velocidad final de nuestra naranja va a
ser negativa pero aquí en la misma
ecuación nos va a decir si el momento es
hacia la derecha o hacia la izquierda no
tienen que preocuparse
simplemente despejen esto dos menos 2.1
ya que restamos 2.1 de ambos lados de la
igualdad nos va a quedar menos 0.1
kilogramos metros por segundo y esto va
a ser igual al momento final de la
naranja que es 0.4 kilogramos por la
velocidad final de la naranja y
dividimos ambos lados
0.4 kilogramos y nos va a quedar menos
0.25 metros por segundo y esta va a ser
la velocidad final de la naranja y nos
daremos cuenta de que no teníamos que
haber deducido la dirección de la
naranja como lo hicimos anteriormente
aquí solita la ecuación al despejar
nuestra incógnita nos va a indicar la
dirección sabré que va a la derecha oa
la izquierda porque aquí el signo si es
negativo me va a decir que va a la
izquierda y si es positivo me dirá que
va a la derecha y en este caso la
velocidad tendrá que ser hacia la
izquierda para respetar la conservación
del momento por lo que esta naranja
justo después de la colisión va a
dirigirse hacia la izquierda esto es lo
que significa ese signo negativo y el
punto 25 es la velocidad a la que va en
esta dirección
punto 25 metros por segundo en resumen
podemos usar la conservación del momento
para encontrar una velocidad desconocida
estableciendo el momento inicial total
del sistema y haciéndolo igual al
momento total
fin
de este sistema debemos tener cuidado
con los signos negativos y si tuviéramos
una velocidad inicial con signo negativo
tendríamos que incluir esa velocidad con
ese signo negativo y si nos queda una
velocidad negativa al final quiere decir
que ese objeto se dirige a sentido con
signo negativo y también solamente
podemos usar la conservación del momento
si estamos seguros de que no hay algún
impulso externo que esté afectando a
alguno de los objetos del sistema y es
por eso que consideramos los instantes
de tiempo justo antes de la colisión y
justo después de la colisión lo hacemos
para que el intervalo de tiempo sea tan
pequeño que no le dé tiempo de
intervenir a alguna fuerza o impulso
externo por lo que la gravedad no nos va
a afectar aquí y también debemos decir
que aquí la manzana estaba colgando
apenitas de la rama ya que si este
carrito hubiera estado bien agarrado de
la rama hubiéramos tenido una fuerza
externa que nos ocasionaría un impulso
externo por lo que suponemos que ésta
ya estaba a punto de caer por sí sola de
esta manera no tenemos ningún impulso
externo y podemos usar la conservación
del momento